to present the next award to compare  competent to contemporary film stars she  copped an Oscar for cactus flower and  can soon be seen in foul play he was  nominated for Midnight Cowboy and is  currently riveting audiences in coming  home now they're both coming here Goldie  Hawn and Jon Voight  we're here to present that most  important award one of the original  eight awards the Award for Best  Cinematography this year's nominees for  cinematography award filmer stigman for  Close Encounters of the Third Kind Fred  J Coney camphor islands in the stream  Douglas Slocum for Julia William a  Fraker for looking for mr. Goodbar  Robert searches for the turning point  I would like to thank you first to this  country the American people who gave me  a second life I would like to thank my  old masters in the Hungarian film school  Illes Jorge boycotts Kabira and Janos  burger  also I would like to thank you all of  you